so listening is a trust building
exercise
right if you've if you're in a rel take
it down to a personal relationship if
you've been if you've ever had romantic
relationships a loved one right um
um
making someone feel heard
doesn't mean you're wrong
saying sorry
doesn't mean you're wrong it just means
you take accountability for your for
your actions and i think it is important
that when somebody objects to
vaccination that we don't demonize or
villainize them
but we
attempt to
hear them
make them
feel heard doesn't mean we have to agree
but they have to feel heard
and you
know listening is not hearing the words
it you know it's making the other person
feel that they were heard it's it's
we don't get to decide when when hearing
has happened when listening that they do
and and by the way it's not 100
successful either you know because some
people are just hell-bent on and but
that's a minority
and so i think the exercise is sitting
down with people and say
tell me tell me what's what you're going
through tell me what you're afraid of i
want to understand because we're trying
to make everyone safe i i want to i want
to hear what what your thing is and let
them tell their story we have no answers
we're not there to object we're not
there to react we're not that to fix or
tell them that they're wrong
women are better than this than men
um
uh
uh
uh
and i think that has to happen and it
can happen simultaneously they are not
mutually exclusive
um i'll give you one one example which
is i have a friend who
uh
refused to get vaccinated
and i sat down with her and i said
tell me tell me your reasoning
right
she goes well um
this new technology like i don't wanna
we don't know it hasn't been out long
enough like we don't know
so what i hear is fear of the unknown
okay i go go on
and she i let her talk and say her thing
and explain all the things and i and
then and i simply said so you're afraid
of the mrna
technology right yes i don't want them
screwing with my dna
i said well just so you know
it's 20 year old technology but then i
found something i could agree with her
but but you're right
it is the first time it's been
commercialized
you're absolutely right this is the
first time we've put it in the market so
i affirmed her fear
and then i said do you get flu shots
every year she goes i do
i said okay johnson johnson
is a good old-fashioned flu shot it's a
different technology it's not mr mrna so
you're 100 right if you're afraid
of
of the new technology don't get modern
or pfizer but johnson johnson is it's
just like a flu shot it's the same old
tech
and she went it is and it is she went
and got a modern shot
[Laughter]
because she just wanted to be heard
because most of her friends when she
said i'm not getting vaccinated yelled
at her told her she was stupid told her
she's an idiot told her she's letting
her friends down told her she's making
other people sick told her she's a risk
to society
that doesn't make somebody's mind open
up all i did was let her feel heard
i think we do we can't we have to do
that